Let's look at the solution to
our address translation quiz.
We have a 16 bit virtual address
space and a four entry page table,
that means that the most significant two
bits of the 16 bit address are the page
number, the remaining 14 bits
are going to be the page offset.
So this 16 bit address can be
written like this in binary.
F0F0.
The most significant two bits are really
the page number, which corresponds
to this entry in the page table,
because this is three, so we need to
look at this entry in the page table.
In this particular address we have 001F.
These two bits correspond to
this entry in the page table.
So now we can write out the physical
address that corresponds
to this virtual address.
It is going to contain
the frame number from
entry number three in the page table.
Which is going to be 1 7.
Concatenated with the page offset
which is going to be 1 1 etc.
And we can know write it
out it's going to be 0F0F0.
And then we have F and this is five.
It's a 20 bit address so
it will have five hex digits.
Similarly here we are looking
at entry number zero here, so
it's going to be 1F,
followed by the page offset.
So it's going to have 00 and
then the remaining digits
are going to be the same.
So it's going to have F10 and then C7.
C because it's 1100 and
7 because it's 0111.
So this is the physical address for
this particular virtual address.